well um I I decided to share the
materials with three Laboratories mainly
at Harvard University
we have a laboratory with the best
instruments in the world
but also with UC Berkeley and the broker
Corporation in Germany that has some
x-ray fluorescence analyzers that nobody
else has and when I shift the materials
to Germany I had to declare what is
inside the box and I said sand and then
I had to declare the commercial value of
it and I said no commercial value it has
enormous scientific value of course yeah
and you know it took millions or maybe
even billions of years for this material
to arrive to Earth by the way it was not
a matter of gravity